es el nuevo pedido de la Fiscalía de 36
meses contra Pedro Castillo es por los
delitos de organización criminal tráfico
de influencias y colusión algunos
juristas con los que he conversado para
este reporte me afirman que si este
viernes la el poder judicial aprueba
este de nuevo requerimiento de la
fiscalía a partir del viernes se
comenzarán a contabilizar los 36 meses
de prisión preventiva y me afirman que
porque la legislación peruana es así
este nuevo requerimiento de 36 meses o
sea que es la medida de mayor duración
va a absolver a los 18 meses de
reclusión que fue ordenada anteriormente
contra Pedro Castillo por los delitos de
rebelión y conspiración que la justicia
peruana ordenó contraer en diciembre
pasado Francisco Qué posibilidades hay
de que la justicia apruebe esos 36 meses
de depresión preliminar y cuáles son las
reacciones de la defensa
todo indica que la corte va a avalar
esta situación que está pidiendo la
fiscalía porque Fuentes judiciales me
señalan que existen elementos que va a
usar el Ministerio Público como son
testimonios de Testigos pruebas y
también documentos que van a sostener
ante la justicia peruana ahora este
escenario que es lo que va a ocurrir que
la defensa de Pedro Castillo va a avalar
o mejor dicho va a tratar de que surja
efecto la medida cautelar que han puesto
ante la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos Y obtener un fallo un
fallo que a ellos les permita tratar de
anular todo lo actuado ante lo que ha
sido la situación del Congreso que
destituyó a Pedro castillo y también la
fiscalía que está haciendo todas estas
acusaciones esas diligencias que han
llevado a que Pedro Castillo esté en
prisión preventiva la estrategia de la
defensa de Pedro Castillo es tener un
fallo favorable que les permita a ellos
ponerlo ante la justicia peruana y
ordenar la liberación de Pedro castillo
y que sea repuesto en el cargo me han
señalado que van a tratar de sentar
jurisprudencia en base a una medida
cautelar que fue usada por el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro cuando él era
alcalde de Bogotá puso un recurso de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos para que le devuelvan el cargo
En la alcaldía de Bogotá